[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight if you've been paying attention
to the news lately you're probably
confused about a bunch of things but you
know one fact for sure James Comey is a
better person than you are
he's a virtuous man honest decent
chivalrous integrity might be his middle
name though he would never admit it
because he's also incredibly humble come
he doesn't make the kind of grubby moral
compromises that characterize your sad
mediocre life like Lincoln or the Buddha
commis ideals are high and he lives them
he has said that repeatedly in cable
news interviews so obviously it is true
how good a person is Jim Comey will
consider what he decided to do when he
left the FBI he's not giving lectures on
law enforcement matters on how to
unravel international money laundering
rings or stop drug trafficking that
would be too obvious too temporal
instead Jim Comey is teaching the rest
of us about leadership how to be better
people
his is a moral mission I could be useful
by offering people a vision of what
ethical leadership looks like it's
hilarious actually
but it's not that surprising keep in
mind that hypocrisy is the signature
fact of this moment 2018 whatever public
figures are scolding you for doing they
are almost certainly doing themselves
and avidly if in secret
the ones who lecture you about feminism
turn out to be sexual predators every
anti-gun activist seems to have an armed
bodyguard in a world like that it is not
surprising that James
mr. integrity Comey left the FBI in an
ethical cloud the DOJ is long-awaited
inspector general's report apparently
accuses Comey of ignoring the directives
of his superiors of being insubordinate
in order to pursue his own agenda that
is not a small charge in a law
enforcement agency but again it's not
surprising in this case Danny Colson is
a former Deputy Assistant Director of
the FBI he joins the sentence Colson
thank you for coming on No thank you I
enjoyed your monologue though is awesome
well it was heartfelt
and none of this is surprising because
it's always the people accusing you of
something who are doing that very thing
but I still am a little
shocked by what we know why won't we
think we know I mean there are leaks
about this IG report and we'll see it's
coming out 500 pages or so soon but from
what we think we know Comey is being
accused of insubordination which is not
a small thing in the FBI is that correct
oh no it's grounds for dismissal
absolutely that's a you have to follow
orders and they have to be lawful orders
but you're you're obliged to follow if
you don't then then they get rid of you
and land rightly so
so assess what we think the IG report
says about how he handled the Hillary
Clinton email investigations in the
light of your own experience working on
big investigations like a Ron contra
which you were involved in what do you
think of his the job he did well I think
we'd have to do a term paper on that
Tucker we could you could do a master's
thesis and all the things that went
wrong in that case from the very first
day did his press conference where he
exonerated Hillary Clinton and then
reopened the case on the Anthony Weiner
matter we all knew that was wrong that's
something you don't do you don't have to
have the IG tell you that if you ever
commanded a major investigation or a
field Division you know you do nothing
that will affect the outcome of a
political election and he ignored that I
was flabbergasted when I saw him do it
and then we could go on and on and on
about how you didn't let the FBI do his
job he acquiesced I'm not having a grand
jury which I was only there 31 years I
never saw that but maybe I missed
something and then he called it a matter
acquiesced to Loretta Lynch's demand
that he called him that matter you know
being a leader doesn't mean you sail in
calm waters being a leader means you you
fight the headwinds you fight the storms
and you lead your agency appropriately
he just didn't do that he never put on
his FBI hat he always wore his
Department of Justice hat and made the
decisions he had no business making so I
have a big problem with what you just
said you said you were there for 31
years you saw a lot of Investigations
take place and you've never seen a
situation like this where a grand jury
wasn't called did is that what she said
absolutely that's what I said from the
most minor investigation to those major
investigation you cannot do your job as
an agent or a commander or prosecutor
without a grand jury and the fact that
this is a major investigation of
national importance and he acquiesced to
not being allowed to have a grand jury
he should have gone to Congress he
should have demanded an independent
counsel he said done a lot of things you
have to buck the head and water some
time he didn't do that and I think it
frankly shouldn't like him courage why
do you think they didn't want a grand
jury they didn't want to find out what
happened it's very simple if you can
help if you bring people in for the
grand jury gets to pick grand jury
subpoenas you can compel testimony in
grant immunity you can subpoena
documents and information and without
that tool you're just begging for
cooperation the FBI never looked at the
Democratic Party sir I'm sorry the
server that the Democrats had to manage
their land they were supposedly high
they never got that they said no well if
you don't have a grand jury you're not
gonna get it so you know this isn't Boy
Scouts going on and trying to sell you
some candy or something then when the
FBI comes with a grand jury then you
comply and if you don't have a grand
jury spirit you're not gonna find out
what happened and clearly did not what
this story's ated from day one is
perspective on how the FBI in functional
times operates and you just provided
that and I really appreciate mr. Colson
thank you for that thank you I enjoyed
it